in this episode of cloud performance
analysts we take a look at a service
that powers billion user systems
BigTable will we set enough places for
performance stay tuned to find out when
it comes to performance at scale there's
very few products that truly represent
that term the way that cloud BigTable
does to date BigTable is a technology
behind the majority of Google products
including Gmail maps and YouTube each of
which serves multi billion active users
and since BigTable is part of Google
cloud platform it's available to use in
your applications as well but before you
run off into the weeds switching over
your database to use it we need to take
a look at how things work and show how
it should and shouldn't be used so let's
take a look under the hood as a massive
generalization cloud BigTable can be
described as three systems working
together first you have a front-end
server pool second you have a set of
compute nodes that handle connections a
KA the BigTable cluster and thirdly you
have a scalable backend of storage now
see a client request goes through a
front-end server pool before they are
sent to the cloud BigTable node
therefore each node in the cluster
handles a subset of requests for the
entire system and the front ends will
handle balancing these connections
depending on the type of action that the
connection is interested in and what
table it's wanting to work on to store
the underlying data in each of your
tables cloud BigTable shards the data
into multiple tablets where each tablet
contains a contiguous range of rows
within the table I know a lot of
vernacular and here's the important
thing when it comes to tablets they can
be reassigned to different nodes in your
cluster on-demand allowing BigTable to
scale and rebalance seamlessly as your
usage patterns change for example as
reads and writes to a specific tablet
increase cloud BigTable might split it
in two in order to isolate hot rows and
improve performance from here you can
clearly see that BigTable does not act
like other relational databases and more
to the point while it scales amazingly
well and isolates hotspots gracefully
that doesn't make it a perfect use case
for every scenario see cloud BigTable
excels at handling very large amounts of
data like terabytes over relatively long
periods of
timelike days this is because big table
needs time to learn your access patterns
and the data needs time to be large
enough to warrant usage across all of
the nodes in your cluster this makes it
a perfect fit for things like time
series data marketing data low latency
serving financial data IOT data and
graph data basically systems with lots
of data and contiguous usage now if your
data needs are small like less than 300
gigs or if your interactions last for
short periods of time then check out the
article linked in the description below
where we list some other technologies
that might be a better fit for your
application likewise don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more great cloud performance Atlas
content because when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts